[Music]
did you know that there are two pirates
of the caribbean scripts currently in
development so could jack sparrow fans
see johnny depp reprise his iconic role
now that his defamation trial against
ex-wife amber heard is over the answer
may surprise you
finally after more than a month of
deliberation the jury hearing johnny
depp and amber heard's competing
defamation lawsuits has reached a
verdict to briefly recap heard and depp
were married from 2015 to 2017 and heard
alleges that depp was abusive to her
during this time in 2018 heard
identified herself as a public figure
representing domestic abuse in an essay
for the washington post
depp characterized allegations as a hoax
and claims that heard of being the one
abusing him
i can't say that i'm embarrassed because
i know that i'm doing the right thing
depp then claims that the allegation
caused him to lose out on lucrative
acting roles in late 2018 depp sued
heard in virginia for defamation seeking
50 million dollars in damages
the impact on deb's career is central to
his lawsuit under questioning from his
own lawyer depp claims that disney
dropped him from the pirates of the
caribbean franchise after heard's essay
was published heard responded with a
counter suit over depp's hoax
allegations claiming that depp
orchestrated a campaign to get her fired
from aquaman and from her job as a
l'oreal spokesperson depp already lost a
similar defamation lawsuit in the united
kingdom in november 2020 and an appeal
over that decision the following march
however on june 1st 2022 the american
jury sided with depp on all three counts
of defamation
awarding him 15 million dollars in
compensatory and punitive damages the
jury also upheld one of herd's claims of
defamation awarding her 2 million
dollars in compensatory damages now that
the verdict is in here's how it could
affect dep's role in the pirates of the
caribbean franchise going forward
currently there are two pirates of the
caribbean scripts in development which
would make the sixth and seventh
installments in the franchise producer
jerry bruckheimer spoke about johnny
depp's future as jack sparrow weeks
before the verdict was reached
when asked if disney was planning to
cast depp in the sixth film brackheimer
responded not at this point
as it turns out though there might not
be a need for depp embarrassed to the
caribbean six anyway bruckheimer also
revealed that the script is centered on
a female lead with margot robbie in mind
that would seem to eliminate the need
for jack sparrow to factor into the
story on the other hand the seventh film
isn't centered around robbie's possible
character which could leave room for
jack sparrow to return in some capacity
bruckheimer added that the future is yet
to be decided so bruckheimer was already
leaving the door open for a possible
depth return before the verdict was
reached script specifics aside the
biggest question is whether disney wants
to work with depp again or not the
travel has undoubtedly tarnished depp's
reputation still bruckheimer's comments
don't explicitly rule out dep's
potential return therefore there's no
guarantee depp will ever play jack
sparrow again
but it sounds like it hasn't been ruled
out at the same time it's important to
consider that disney is only half of the
equation johnny depp may not even want
to come back as jack sparrow after all
he's gone through and how his
relationship with the walt disney
company has shifted in recent years in
fact during the trial depp confirmed
previous testimony that his connection
with the company has changed so
drastically that he wouldn't return to
the role no matter how much disney
offered
nothing on this earth would get you to
go back and work with disney on a
pirates of the caribbean film that is
true mr rottenborn the actor explained
during his trial testimony there was a
deep and distinct sense of feeling
betrayed by the people that i've worked
hard for people that i delivered a
character to that they initially
despised but i stuck to my guns with the
character and it seemed to work
while this could be pure hyperbole
considering the circumstances depth's
likely serious for the time being time
will tell when the next parts of the
caribbean project will sail into
theaters but a sing stand at the time of
the johnny depp amber heard verdict
don't expect to see captain jack sparrow
back in action when it does
if you or someone you know is dealing
with domestic abuse you can call the
national domestic violence hotline at
1-800-799-7233
you can also find more information
resources and support at their website
[Music]